what's going on reject nation is Greg
over here it's John O'Brien here to
review the movie for it to the camera
boy and didn't in tune those homes are
before we hop into the review we wanted
to give a shout out to her friends at
movie chat or movie chat is the largest
online community for discussing movies
TV shows actors celebrities this site
was created following the shutdown of
IMDb's popular message boards that
happened earlier this year they're here
to fill the void and they have a lot of
movies a lot of posts pretty much
anything you can think of the thousands
of users already so if after watching
this review of dead men tell no tales if
you want to discuss the move even
further or any other movie for that
matter click the link of movie chat in
the description box below
all right on to did Nintendo pounds we
did our retro review series of the first
four we finally made our way to watching
dead men tell no tales
yeah with almost every youtuber not
liking this film Rotten Tomatoes giving
it a 35% I'm here to tell you I kind of
disagree I actually enjoyed this film
went through quite a bit I think I had a
rollicking good time while I was
watching it it wasn't like on the edge
of my seat is nowhere near as good as
the first two it's not I'm nowhere near
luckily not great it's not necessarily a
good blockbuster perhaps but you know
what I had a good time especially at the
end of the long marathon I thought it
was yeah better more enjoyable than
three and four that's probably the
biggest takeaway that I have for it was
I think I only enjoyed this film as much
as I did because I saw three and four
like the day before I saw three two days
again for the day before coming off of
two really bad huh and then we'll going
into this you can't help but notice it's
a definite improvement part three I
think the majority don't like in act
feel like some people might say that
this is not better than part three I
personally found this much easier to
enjoy throughout it significantly better
than part four because it actually goes
out of its way to direct and capture
edit the movie with actual style
throughout the film humor is really
present I
I laughed a good amount of times and
they got new cast members that I thought
were great you know I don't know if this
is a spoiler I don't know why people
think it it's really we don't want to
mention the guy who plays - Brenton
Thwaites place we don't want to give
away who he is but they say his name in
the credits and it's pretty obvious who
he is when you see the trailers and
featurettes and the and some people kind
of reveal though it wasn't really Creole
I mean things are sort of the movie
starts off about a reveal it for a lot
of it yeah minor spoiler he kind of got
to go into it again father it's not a
spoiler it's it's the vanity and it is
intend returner it says his name on IMDB
I think hear the name Turner and a
pirate era a movie like you're gonna
yeah you're going to make that
Association do not ending looks like
Orlando Bloom yeah I don't lose it for a
bit of the film so if we spoil that for
you sorry sorry but it's not really well
no it's not
they don't know I had information like
it's some grand revelation when it
finally comes out now there's other
reveals in the film that are definite
spoilers if we talked about it other
major reveals and there's one reveal
where I didn't see it coming and I
thought it was handled quite well
involving Geoffrey Rush's character
Barbosa that's all I'll say about it
even that's not even really I can't even
tell you that you're probably not even
be able to guess what it is and you're
watching the film really yeah it would
start with some positives for the film I
thought it might be the other ones that
this film had some sequences in here
that I thought were exceptionally fun to
watch you know there's a scene in the
trailer that you see where Jack's about
to get his head chopped off and that the
way the entire sequence plays out is
really entertaining it's really funny
and it shot really well and another
thing that people are commenting a lot
on are the shark scenes and now
gentlemen the shark scene is is
fantastic actually as I'm sorry really
am good and part three didn't really
expand the universe much but part four
you know sort of added at least a couple
things and I liked it they added here as
well you know like you said you
mentioned the shark scene but also I
liked Captain Salazar you know play by a
Javier Bardem and his crew like it's
kind of the same concept we've seen a
lot of time dead viruses yeah Jack
Sparrow
higher it was some kind of curse played
by a great actor like but the designs of
that character and their story I thought
really cool that they added a flavor
like I like these movies take advantage
of the globe you know and have different
kinds of people from all over the world
you know as character I would put it up
there I would say I mean this might not
be saying a lot it's kind of nice a
alien covenant is like the third best
alien period this is like the third best
pirates movie in my opinion after
watching five of them in a row I can
confidently say pirates five is the
third best one in terms of you and we're
known if there's a watch ability enjoy
ability and even re-watch ability it
definitely has a lot more soul than the
fourth one and it's definitely a lot
more focused than the third one I feel
like they're slowly getting if pirates
for was their shift into making more
blockbuster you know Hollywood style
pirates movies they've gotten a little
bit better at it with this one I thought
yeah yeah I don't think it's anywhere
near as bad as people have been making
it out to be I just don't yeah I don't
agree with that yeah yeah it's not great
it's not great and it's it but it's
certainly enjoyable there's a lot of fun
to be had like a copy of our damn he's a
really good villain in the film he's not
he's not exactly in it throughout but
he's really good Captain Barbossa well I
always like that the films always go out
of their way
specifically with Barbosa to make him
different a little different in each
installment he's always cunning he's
always you know he's always it has his
own interest at heart the most selfish
and you can fire it but they always
change up his status and where he's at
in life much more than they do
especially more than Jack Sparrow
there's always a different type of
position he's in I always feel like he's
the Mike the most consistently
interesting thing over the course of all
these movies is Burpo's Andrew Geoffrey
Rush nails the role again he did a
fantastic job with the character he
always shows up man yeah and he's always
good like he always seems like he's
having a good time even if you know the
material is less than what it was before
and the two main newcomers Brenton
Thwaites as Henry Turner I thought he
was very natural he's definitely like
they cast the viewer if they're looking
for the person to be the son of care not
dinner
you're like young metod people that is
the guy he looks just like that me yeah
today and he does a really good job in
the trail that make it look like he'll
probably have a lot more screen time
than he actually gets in the film but
he's still really good and he's
naturally in the film as well I enjoy
what he's there and also the other girl
could highest scuttle area yeah playing
Kareena Smith oh come on really good
yeah fantastic
I thought that Shane is where women are
kicking ass and films Mabel she was kind
of the standouts new thing about the
movie for me I thought she had a lot of
charm a lot of charisma I thought her
story was pretty good ya know what I
liked and what for max is really good
yeah yeah I liked watching her a lot in
fact in terms of just straight up
performances I thought she was one of
the best things about this Oh totally
that's easy her turns are busy yeah up
to the top and Javier Bardem feel like
they're all bringing a lot of a game a
lot of person yeah and I can feel the
effort of this film doing its best to
hearken back more to the first one in
spirit yeah in terms of spirit and tone
and I like the plot of them looking for
the Trident episode Poseidon's try to
sudden side and strider yeah always
taking they keep taking on you know
popular you know sea mysticism legendary
tales and throwing them into this
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise yeah
and the point seems to be what if all
those legends were real yeah yeah and I
like the plot of what Henry Turner's
motivation is okay final about that we
don't give away with everyone knows will
turn kid we won't give away what it
plotted necessarily you can probably
figure it out pretty yeah but everyone's
looking for the Trident for very
specific reasons and Javier Bardem
Catherine Salazar is after Jack Sparrow
for very specific reasons as well which
I could were kind of reveal on the
trailer Jack Sparrow did something that
caused him to pretty much be tea curse
the way he is yeah it was nice to be a
little bit surprises because I didn't
know the nature of that character I
thought he was just a pirate guy you
know I'm not going to get too big into
it but I thought it was kind of a nice
surprise to learn about those characters
and where they came from because they're
not standard issue pirate captain and
Carrick
and I really think John and I probably
enjoyed it more than what most people
online are saying only because we watch
the other ones like we've watched it
back-to-back like one yeah one day at a
time so I think if we like let the other
movies process for a couple for a few
years then we were visited this we might
have had less of an opinion on it but in
terms of stepping it up from the last
two that's why I'm here but with that
being said there are some definite flaws
that I couldn't help but notice and the
maintenance law I have with the film the
main issue I have is Captain Jack
Sparrow Johnny Depp no doubt he's still
funny
he makes you laugh but what he's a lot
more present in this movie than in the
fourth movie like I spent a lot of the
fourth way or invested actually kind of
furrowing my brow feeling is he just
feel checked out and in this movie he
doesn't feel checked out he's not the
first movie or the second movies Jack
Sparrow but he has more of a rhythm he
looks like he's more invested in yelling
character again was that being said
though the writing of his character has
really gone downhill all the writing all
the writings gone downhill but
specifically with Jack because one thing
that the first two even three III think
yep a specimen only three it does it for
sure commit what makes Jack so special
is that he constantly comes across like
he's just some dumb drunk pirate who you
find out is really clever
there's always something that he does
where you find there's always something
up his sleeve which makes them
mysterious unpredictable engaging and as
the franchise continues you get less
mysterious and less unpredictable and
here a it just kind of is like the least
essential to the entire plot be there's
no mystery about him it's like that it
never seems like there's something else
up his sleeve there never seems like
there's something more going on it's
pretty much like okay here's what Jack's
gonna here's what we need Jack all right
now he's there and the worst part is is
that any crazy situation Jack gets into
these others saved by other people or
dumb luck he doesn't boil anything the
laws of physics stop working in his face
like what the thing is is that he never
it never he never does something that
shows ah there's the clever
Jack that we know there's the there's
this smart Jack that we know that one
that could surprise us everything is all
just he's just a cartoon who gets saved
by luck or other people doing this job
but what is especially a cartoon in this
movie because he spent the first act of
it like sloppy drunk you know as a gang
drunker than ever yeah on it to the
point where I thought they were going to
make that like a real plot element like
oh maybe maybe your drinking is becoming
a problem Jack because like you're
actively screwing up a heist right now
and the movie sets it up it sets up his
character in a way where you think oh
they're fixing the thing that I had the
biggest issue in the fourth film which
is there's no emotional motivation or
any room for Jack to grow and then the
way the film sets up Jack where he's
back to being on his own his crew leaves
him and then I kind of don't even think
about that anyone remember that yeah
they're gonna do that kind of like past
review I am washed-up story I am and
they know they don't really and the the
thing is to me I feel like that would
have been a better way or a more
interesting way to take it cuz to me I
feel like you could make Jack Sparrow
work even as a lead character if you
just kind of treat him like ash from
Evil Dead and singing back to the other
pirates movies like I'm sure those those
movies were inspiration somewhere but if
you look at Ash like even though he's
always the same kind of buffoon II guy
he does change every time we check in on
him you know and I feel like that would
be a good idea for Jack Sparrow
absolutely because ashen Jack have this
to have a similar characteristic which
lady said buffoon II they're kind of
dumb but then they do something we were
like that's later the hero of this movie
or Chevy and that's and but Johnny Depp
in this one he's just dump she's dumped
it like that it doesn't do anything yeah
he's just a wacky character who
sometimes gets to be badass because
anything and that's I don't know like
that's the biggest flaw in this phase of
the Pirates movies for me all around
it's just all the edges are a bit dulled
out like the dialogue isn't interesting
anymore the production values aren't as
high although they do look better in
this movie a color palette in this movie
is better like everything looks better
than the four it oh and compared to
Stranger Tides I think this is
step up from stranger time step up from
janky value I can see you liking part
three more have a find it very hard to
believe if you like on Stranger Tides
more than yes I guess felt like they
didn't split a lot of the differences
it's like the dialogue still isn't great
so really plot II but it's a little bit
better yeah and you know the pace is
fine like they spend the first part of
the movie doing kind of fun set pieces
and stuff like there is fun stuff and
it's doesn't a bit shorter like 20
minutes or yeah it's like two hours and
15 instead of two hours of 45 or
something like that at the end of the
day you know it's a pretty okay blog to
me it played like a pretty okay blog
perhaps special it's not magical but in
terms of a fifth installment for a
franchise I was greatly dying it's one
of the better ones up as of late yeah I
don't know it's weird it's weird to kind
of come up with a consensus for the
tabie because like I do see what
everyone is saying I'm not trying to
argue with whatever will withhold
opinions on it but I don't know yeah
maybe just coming off like a sick binge
I'm like yeah this was I had a fine time
one of the easier ones to enjoy yeah
exactly and it brought you know a couple
neat designs it's still the same like
Jack's looking for something okay the
British are also looking for that
nothing an eccentric pirate play by
great actor is looking for that
something like it's the same kind of
formula they do some cool supernatural
stuff the set pieces are the fighting
sequences and there's some real laughs
that we have and yeah and and and you
know they really make the villains
menacing when they show up yeah and the
designs of those guys are great so it
all comes down to again it's like alien
covenant it's like what do you want out
of the ex you know how would say is
enjoyable and entertaining I wasn't
bored yeah yeah yeah yeah you might not
remember it once you've left it's not
really distinct yeah but it's a fine
time at the movie yeah
for sure for sure and before we wrap up
this video I wanted to give a shout out
to the man Aldrin diamond II we recently
launched some t-shirts over at shotgun
Spreadshirt complex the real rejects and
he bought two t-shirts and he says the
photo here you go
over there rockin the nipple chills one
that's my quote keep it chill that's my
quote right there and there's a Jean and
I as the Devil's Rejects there's no
female in this group so since the guys
from the Devil's Rejects yeah not in
Gregg South Aldrin G thank you so much
for violin being the first person to buy
one of our shirts
I think Aldrin Dee's Filipino hair who
looks Filipino he does he yeah he looks
like a cuddle bear Oh like spider-man's
friend yeah Filipino chubby guide
spider-man home [ __ ] alright guys well
what do you think a dead men tell no
tales what would you rank it as as of
the out of all five pirates movies what
would you rank it as you can subscribe
to the Rio rejects check out gat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram click
that notification bell as well check out
our exclusive perks and content over at
patreon have a good night